well president Trump seems to have the
back of embattled environmental
protection agency chief Scott Pruett at
least for the time being president gave
Pruett a pep talk during a phone
conversation yesterday but sources tell
us there are still concerns about recent
negative headlines in other words that
does not mean Pruett will escape the
growing scrutiny over some questionable
expenses of course mana Doug mackelway
looks at the situation tonight Scott
Pruett sir you support separate a tepid
endorsement in the future tense for
president Trump's besieged EPA
Administrator Scott Pruett as he faces
several new accusations today two
Democratic congressman wrote EPA's
Inspector General requesting an
investigation into Pruitt's reported
sweetheart deal on this Capitol Hill
condo owned by energy lobbyists their
letter says quote EPA approved the
pipeline expansion plan of a Canadian
energy company who employed mr. Hart as
a lobbyist at the same time mr. Pruit
was leasing the condo at a below market
rate an EPA Ethics opinion written after
the rattle found Pruitt's $1,500 monthly
rent was a reasonable rate but questions
remain whether Pruitt paid only for the
nights he stayed in the condo in an
apparent Airbnb style arrangement all
this after Pruitt faced scrutiny for
other alleged misdeeds his pattern of
first-class air travel
allegedly to enhance security a private
jet was rejected because of its $100,000
monthly cost published reports also
found poets around-the-clock personal
security detail required triple the
staffing of previous administrators and
last September the Washington Post found
the EPA was spending nearly 25 thousand
dollars to build a secure soundproof
booth and Pruitt's office now even some
Republicans are joining the dump of
Pruett chorus representative Carlos
corbello tweeted the epa administrator
should resign or president Trump should
dismiss him right now Pruitt is a marked
man in Washington who would supporters
though say the barrage of attacks is a
testament to his effectiveness Scott
Pruett has been a lightning rod he has
been the incarnation of evil for
environmental groups and climate
activists so they're doing everything
they can to go after him
who would ignored shouted questions at a
ceremony today marking his latest
affront to environmentalist rolling back
President Obama's plan to increase
average fuel economy standards to 54
point five miles per gallon by the year
2025 and the standards remained in
effect massive changes would have hit
car manufacturing and the vehicles
motorists buy it statutorily kills the
American SUV as we know it a federal
lawsuit will likely be needed to resolve
the federal-state dispute it could take
years and leave automakers in limbo
what automobile manufacturers most want
out of any new fuel economy standards is
consistency and predictability so they
can make long-term plants not an easy
thing to do when Washington and state
policy makers are this polarized right
Doug thank you